[Music]
just over 30 miles away from the
slovenian capital
this alpine lake looks like it belongs
on the cover of a storybook
[Music]
with a fairytale cliffside castle an
emerald green freshwater lake and views
of some of the highest peaks of the
julian alps lake bled and its island
church make a postcard perfect scene
to visit the assumption of mary church
you must catch a ride on a wooden boat
known as a plenta
plentas have been taking visitors to the
island in the middle of the lake for
centuries
[Applause]
once reaching the island it's a 99 stone
step climb to reach the entrance to the
church
it is said that if a groom could carry
his bride up these steps and ring a
wishing belt at the top
the marriage would be a happy one
the church is most famous for this bell
which was made in the early 16th century
and is said to be a gift from the pope
[Music]
legend has it this was the church's
second bell
the first was bought for the church by
an inconsolable widow in honor of her
late husband who was murdered and then
thrown into the lake
when boatman brought it across to the
church an unexpected storm hit and the
bell sunk to the bottom
it is said if you listen closely in the
dead of night you can hear the sunken
bell ringing from the depths of this
picturesque lake
[Music]
you